all right what's the next one let's look
at the next category what is the next
category
best best tangent this whole podcast is
a tangent damn straight
i don't know how we like narrowed this
one down because i think i feel like the
entire podcast
every moment this one was based on
the severity of the tangent yeah how far
it went yeah
how far you just did a 90 degree turn
and uh yeah there's a lot let's look at
the categories though all right
ladies and gentlemen this one is by far
my favorite i i see this one winning
based off how strongly people will
remember this one
yeah because it was so recent i remember
this and and when when it came
out when it came up we all were like
what the [ __ ] is this yeah like so i
could just on that i could see this
okay play the clip i have so
my shower curtain
what is going on what is actually going
on i love the like
just half a second pause of just our
brains processing what he just said
the challenge came out of nowhere
absolutely out of nowhere i don't think
i've ever felt physical whiplash from a
conversation until
until like i was on a podcast with
ladies that's true that's true like
like you know you like compared to the
drifting episode where we were like
[ __ ]
feeling the g's turning the corner yeah
now the ladybit episode was like i felt
more g's
having a conversation with ladybird than
i did ever did during the drifting
episode man
and then the second one is talking about
poop i mean this could be anything it
could be any of them
play the clip why do we talk about [ __ ]
as like every time
don't don't [ __ ] use this use this
[Laughter]
is that a tangent that's more like a
best intro
because the intro can't even do an intro
we literally tangented
right at the beginning i think it's
supposed to symbolize as going off
yeah yeah yeah yeah this isn't the like
the clip but it's kind of like
symbolizing yeah i mean i mean
i mean it's just like a theme where just
like whenever we talk about poop it is a
big tangent yeah chris hijacks a yacht i
remember this one i remember this one
i got really drunk and early hijacked a
boat with my estonian friend in london
wait wait wait wait you can't just say
that
i can't go into detail no way come on i
love how he couldn't even like talk
about it
he's just like i'mma just drop this
bombshell and see you later
i remember there was like a few stories
that chris taught in that podcast we
were just like
out of nowhere like how he's like surf
elon musk or something like that
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah like a castle
right yeah that's right
i remember that exact moment because
because like i dropped
i was opening a bottle of wine and i
dropped the wine bottle bottle opener
with such disgust
that he hadn't told me about this before
watch unlimited blade works and then
that's that's like the main line
timeline so you can enjoy
heaven's feel and then if you want to
enjoy more of the fake franchise you can
because
none of it's technically canon this is
the only episode where i was like when
are they going to stop
like i literally was like i zoned out
and i was like i'm going to come back
into this because i remember this
episode because
it was it was mostly it turned into
mostly a fate episode
yeah even though we didn't plan it at
all and uh that started completely just
from a tangent
and then that's turned into like a 17 to
20 minute tangent
yeah yeah that's uh kind of like rotted
your mind i think
i think i was i was actually i'd never
wanted like to stop recording be like
can we
can we change this we've never done that
before i've never
we've never asked to like move on yeah
yeah but that was the one time i'm like
i'm gonna do it yeah i'm gonna ask
luckily i'm gonna say it i'm gonna stop
just generally going on tangents
the way i talk about americans is like
the way i like like to [ __ ] on my
cousins you know what i mean it's
it's it's like the distant cousin that i
just like to talk [ __ ] about we don't
hate on america we just like making fun
of america
i love how that sentence alone could
have been so out of context yeah i love
talking about americans like i like
[ __ ] on my cousin just
stop the sentence there you have this
one yeah i got this one i mean
for this one host biased ladybird shower
curtain
uh i think that was the tangent that
sticks out to me the most oh that's 100
i think trash taste is like i mean we
talked we tangent about poop
and tangent about america all the time
they're just not like strong enough in
our
yeah in the the memory of an iconic in
terms of the biggest whiplash uh lady
beard number one i say chris hijacks a
yacht number because like
like the shower curtain moment was like
a build up of about 15 more tangents
that we were like
building on to seem like the dumbest of
all yeah
i've never heard a sentence that started
with so my shower code
until this episode you really pushed the
limits yeah
yeah all right who won let us find out
so the best tangent goes to the ladybird
shower curtain surprising well-deserved
landslide this one yeah what was the
percentage for this one this this should
have been one of the biggest ones yeah
probably
29.4 not that much so
yeah those are definitely the biggest
ones well good well done ladybird that's
right
yeah biggest tangent and biggest chat
goes to you